foreign
[Music]
from the session of April 26 23.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
there's a close nay the eyes have it the
house is adjourned the house will attend
to a Prayer by house chaplain Reverend
Bob Smith pastor of Saint Paul's United
thank you before I begin when I was here
in March and I began a prayer in a
certain way one of the representatives
stopped me to tell me a heartwarming
story about their granddaughter Antonia
if you are here today I have the card
that I had said that I would write to
your granddaughter so
and I'm going to begin the prayer this
morning in the same way that I began in
March
good morning God
good morning Mr Speaker and good morning
New Hampshire House of Representatives
let us be in an attitude of Prayer
a loving God
when you spoke to Moses through the
burning bush to lead your children out
of Slavery to their new Promised Land
Moses asked
who am I to lead the people
if they ask me your name
what should I tell them
in Exodus 3 verse 14 God replies
I am the one who always is
just tell them
I am has sent me to you
just like Moses we are sent to lead and
represent the people of this great state
of New Hampshire
help us to remember o God that you are
the one who always is
you are The Great I Am that walks with
us each and every day
be with us as we conduct the business of
the day
and help us to understand the way in
which we are to go
the way that we'll be in the best
interest of the people we represent
it is with gratitude that we serve the
people of New Hampshire
and it is in gratitude that we also
serve you o God
be with all the leaders of this house as
they like Moses lead the way with the
business that will be placed before us
today
give each representative the wisdom to
understand and to reason the legislation
presented
so they can make the best decisions
possible
oh God the one who always is
the chair recognized the member from
Newport representative skip Rollins who
the chair now recognizes Isabella Osgood
a student at Newport High School in our
page for the day who will now sing on
[Music]
yeah I can't hear
turns early light what's up
[Music]
at the
twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
[Music]
we washed were so gallon gently
streaming
[Music]
bursting in
again
[Music]
free
and the home of the breath
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
the house will attend to request for
leads of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Grossman hatch and
Vincent the day important business
Representatives Bay Buras Linda gold
hacken Phillips Dennis Manion O'Hara
sellers the day illness in the family
Representatives Delorenzo the house will
the day death in the family
these leaves the bathroom shall be
granted unless otherwise sorted by the
house
house will attending introduction
address
Mr Speaker please welcome John Sheehan
son of Representative Sheehan Melanie
and Christopher Osgood parents of the
singer guests of Representative Rollins
they are with us in the gallery today
welcome to another New Hampshire house
[Applause]
speaker
in an email communication on Wednesday
April 26 23.
speaker Packard I had given this a
tremendous amount of thoughts and with
the recent events regarding my health
and ongoing appointments and treatments
I feel as though the doctor's office has
become my second home I understand you
would rather see me on medical leave but
as I mentioned to you before when I
first attempted to resign was that I
feel as though I cannot represent
Rockingham one effectively if I am on
medical leave this is something I have
struggled with since our conversation I
am not one to take a position and not
fulfill the obligation that comes with
it that's not fair to my constituents
the house or you or me whatever energy I
have left I must use it to focus taking
care of my health I've always throughout
my life have put others before me
whether that is the military my days as
an EMT law enforcement career the
countless hours of volunteering to help
communities to helping veterans
I've always been that person people can
look up to to count on and know that I
will take care of things and get things
done I need to take a step back today I
need to put my health first and above
everything else I cannot continue to be
there for everyone if I am not here on
Earth my health has to come first when
and not if I always try to remain
optimistic my health makes a full
recovery I hope to one day return to the
New Hampshire house and continue serving
my constituents in Rockingham district
one if they'll have me again Mr Speaker
I hope you'll understand even though
it's only been a short time it's been an
honor to serve this great state in this
great nation please accept my
resignation thank you Benjamin T
the resignation is accepted with the
regret house will attend to an amendment
to house rules as proposed by the rules
representative Osborne and Wilhelm move
the adoption are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay
the eyes have it
and the amendment is adopted by the
necessary two-thirds vote
the house will attend to Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house and the passage of the Fong
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill 407 relative to regulations on
alcohol
representative hunt moves we concurrence
thank you Mr Speaker
this amendment that was added on is the
bill itself was a couple of different
liquor issues but more importantly some
of you might have heard about Amtrak
having a little problem selling liquor
on their trains and this uh Amendment
will address that problem and that you
yes they can they can they can sell
liquor on the trains while they drive
through New Hampshire
the motion before us is the curb to
concur
on a house bill 407. are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay the eyes have it the
chair recognizes the clerk
speaker the Senate concurs the house and
the passage of the following entitled
bill with amendment in the passage of
which amendment the Senate has to
concurrence of the house house bill 520
relative to Escrow accounts maintained
by licensed non-depository Mortgage
there's a kind of hunting as we Concur
and is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker uh the Senate just
moved the effective date to make it upon
Passage
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 520 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
open post nay the eyes have it the
speaker the Senate concurs the house and
the pastor of the following entitled
bill with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate has the concurrence
of the house house bill 613 relative to
regulation of the individual health
representative hunt moves that we Concur
and is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker uh so this bill is
revising the statute uh related for the
insurance Department's regulated
regulation of a Medicaid expansion since
we did change it in House Bill 2 uh this
the paragraph that was added to is
making sure it harmonizes with what we
passed with the budget
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 613 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
you guys have it and the emotion is
adopted
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs that the house and
the passage of the Fong entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate has the concurrence
of the house house bill 550 relative to
Mr Speaker what the Senate did to this
bill is what they usually do to our
bills where we set up a committee
they've eliminated one of the Senators
that is participating on the committee
so it's from two to one other than that
we support the bill it's exactly same as
we sent to them thank you
the motion before us is to concur on on
House Bill 550 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs the house and the
passage of the phone entitled bill with
Amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 150
thank you Mr Speaker
our committee recommends concurrence on
this bill this bill has to do with soil
amendments and fertilizers and there was
a change to uh when a fertilizer is
deficient
the rebates that can be collected on it
goes instead of for a ton of fertilizer
half ton so I we recommend concurrence
on this bill
[Music]
the motion before us is a concurrence on
House Bill 152. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the house will now attend the consent
calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on
executive departments and administration
Senate Bill 195 removed by
Representatives groda Fred Davis grassy
Marjorie Smith schuit telersky Tony
leckis Alicia leckis Corman and O'Brien
from the committee on Fish and Game and
Marine Resources Senate Bill 15 removed
by Representatives Spillane Hill Tom
Manion nodder Hole Santa nastasso
Sheehan yokella Harrington and Tony
Lucas
are there any barrels to be removed from
a consent calendar
General's moves at consent calendar with
the relevant amendments is printed in
today's house record be adopted are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
there's a post name the eyes have it
in the consent calendar is adopted under
rules of the house from the committee on
children family law Senate Bill 172 FN
is preferred committee on finance from
the committee on the executive
departments and administration Senate
Bill 49 FN has referred to committee on
Ways and Means and Senate Bill
40204 FN is referred to the committee on
finance
the house will attend to the regular
calendar
on criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred Senate Bill 209
relative to providing menstrual hygiene
products that no cost to individuals who
biologically menstruate in the state and
County correctional facilities this is
without recommendation
representative Harriet gothright
is recognized for a motion
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to table
sb209 and I asked for a division vote
the motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 209 are you ready
oh I'm sorry I didn't hear that this is
a division vote members will take their
seats
rules
nice
the motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 209 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
chair my mistake care recognizes
representative roads for parliamentary
integrate
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know
that this body already passed
legislation and Senate to that body
that was written so well
that the legislation in front of you was
sent to us with the expectation
that we would rewrite it to make it
match the verbiage that we already sent
and Mr Speaker if I know that by tabling
this bill
in the event that they screw up the bill
that they have
they can write the amendment and bring
it back to us for us to try to pass
again
the motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 209
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposal press the red button
thank you well members president
opportunity to vote also attend the
357 voting yay nine voting nay
the committee on education to which was
referred Senate Bill 77 relative to
changes in school placement for students
scum dose without recommendation
representative Ladd moves on a pass
thank you Mr Speaker Senate Bill 77
mandates all school boards approved
taxpayer-funded tuition agreements with
private schools
under current law this is an option
school boards have now especially if the
school district does not operate its own
schools for a specific grade level for
example an elementary middle or High
School
but this bills a wolf in sheep's
clothing
proponents of Senate Bill 77 describe it
as housekeeping we've all heard that
before just tidying up some loose ends
that must have accidentally been omitted
back when the Manifest education
hardship law was changed four years ago
following a strong bipartisan effort
that law allows a parent or Guardian to
request a change of school assignment
when a student is experiencing an
education hardship at school
and by law change of school assignments
can be made to another public school or
to an approved private school it's rare
it's done administratively and it's done
with little or no additional cost to the
school district
so at a minimum Senate Bill 77 is
totally unnecessary since assignments
are already being made to another public
school or particularly when a district
does not operate its own public schools
to another approved private school
Bill 77 abuses the intent of the law and
mandates all school boards approve
taxpayer-funded tuition agreements with
private schools even when the district
has their own schools
it's Sneaky it's deceptive and it abuses
an important provision in education law
meant to help kids bring it into a
directive
to approve private private schools
tuition programs at taxpayer expense
it even goes so far as to require
schools
approve
private schools approved by other school
boards in other school districts and I
bet your constituents are going to love
that
so some people don't care about the
destruction of our high performance
public schools and the opportunities and
strong outcomes these schools provide
the children of New Hampshire about 165
000 kids and their families across the
state do
and so do property taxpayers who approve
local school budgets and reach deep into
their pockets to make up for the lack of
State funding a responsibility the
legislature has shirked for too long
so think hard about this vote
think hard about asking your
constituents especially those retired
living on fixed incomes to dig deeper
and use their property taxes to pay for
private school tuition bills when
they're already paying for public
schools
you're going to have to explain this one
so for kids families and taxpayers
please vote no on the ought to pass
motion
thank you Mr Speaker and I do request a
division vote
thank you very much Mr Speaker well
we've heard words like adjectives like
sneaky deceptive destruction of public
schools
that's not what this bill is all about
when we talk about manifest education
hardship and some of you may not be
familiar with that terminology we have
in education law it's been around for of
years
within the Minority Report
it says it's a relatively New Concept a
new education leadership program
hardship program it's not backend
2013 I can recall modifying the Manifest
education our shoot statutes based upon
what was being done in Cambridge
Massachusetts at that time it was also
part of No Child Left Behind
the purpose of manifest education and
hardship
is not to provide another choice
for everybody to go well I don't like
this school I'm going to go to another
one that is not what it was designed for
in fact in working cooperatively would
the New Hampshire school boards
Association and other groups we came
forward with legislation and that's now
statutory law that says this is what
Emmanuel a manifest education hardship
is for
such hardship must be so severe
pervasive or persistent that it
interferes with or limits the ability of
a student to receive an education it's
not where a parent can walk in the door
and say I want my student going to
school a over there because they have a
better algebra program there than they
have in school B
that's none irrational or the hardship
the hardship is for those situations
those rare situations in which a child
is being bullied to the point where they
can't make it in the present school I
experienced that in my own family
ADI youngster in the Middle School who
is now standing athlete
but was being bullied over and over we
talked for the counselor we talked with
the principal they understood it but it
didn't stop
it went on because the kids were
bullying the other my that youngster
so we looked at what are we going to do
back in those days I did not have the
option of manifest education hardship I
had to take and pay for that youngster
to go to another school where she
thrived has now been on the Dean's List
at the University of Maine for four
consecutive years captain of the indoor
and outdoor track team set all kinds of
Records here in New England
in the pentathlon so these options have
to be available they are available now
and if this occurs within a school
district that school district through
the school board has the option
of sending a student to another public
school private school or non-public
school in their District or a school
outside their District
and the schools that they're sending to
they don't have to go out and say well
I'm going to prove this private school
so we can go there we have the
Department of Education right now that's
already approved how many here 98
schools for attendance they've approved
98 schools for attendance which are
non-public schools they've also approved
another 40 schools
which have shown that they've gone
through the accreditation process New
England Association schools and colleges
the New England Association The
Independent Schools and three others
that is a real trip to get that type of
accreditation in fact it's in our
statutes as one of the methodologies for
uh
accountability for providing the
adequate education we are supposed to be
providing to all kids in conclusion
this bill is a result of an oversight in
legislation which was put forth several
years ago there are six sections of law
which speak to this area where you can
send students to as if there's a
manifest education hardship found
this simply corrects an Aaron statue in
the five or six paragraphs the private
school alternative is mentioned along
with Public Schools a public Academy
Etc but however in the sixth paragraph
where that was supposed to be changed
there was oversight and drafting that
was not made so what we're trying to do
is have all six sections in this chapter
agree and parallel each other thank you
very much Mr Speaker
representative San Andreas
there's a member of yield the questions
remember it does not yield
representative San Antonio has requested
a roll call it is sufficiently seconded
motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 77 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Tanner
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know
that this is not a simple change in
wording or an oversight to a
long-standing collaborative process that
has happened between public schools to
place students who are experiencing
extreme manifest hardship to another
Public School
if I know this change will has the
consequence that will force local school
districts to pay full tuition rates at
many schools now non-public private even
out-of-state schools
if I know as a result of this change
that there will be a substantial
increase in the financial burden on
local schools resulting in a raise of
local property taxes
and if I know I don't want to explain to
my constituents why I raise their
property taxes then would I press the
red button to vote no so that another
more responsible motion can be made
thank you
chair recognize representative Ladd for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this bill simply corrects a
technical emission made during the last
update to the Manifest education
hardship statute
and if I know this does not raise your
property taxes
if I know manifest education hardship is
rightfully available as an alternative
education placement granted only in such
hardship cases where it's severe
pervasive or persistent
would I then support this proven program
that's in the best interest of students
by pressing the green button thank you
motion before us is on a pass and Senate
bill 77. it's a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposal press the red button
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
187 voting a 183 voting a
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred Senate Bill 152 FN
act relative to New Hampshire Workforce
training programs having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation Bill ought to pass it's
in Valerie McDonald for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
thank you Mr Speaker good morning
colleagues
I'd like to talk to you for a moment
about our amendment to SB 152 what this
bill does is it creates two new Pathways
within the Career Technical education
departments in schools and high schools
it creates a marine trades pathway and
it creates an offshore wind energy
pathway
now if we're going to be using taxpayer
money to train students for specific
type jobs this should be an investment
that comes out good for both the student
and the taxpayer
the Marine trades portion of this bill
appears to be a good fit however the
offshore wind energy does not first of
all
these offshore wind jobs do not yet
exist here
they are prospective jobs and we should
not be training students for something
that we don't know is even going to
exist
and if we do we can expect that in
coming years there will be further
lobbying of this body to further
subsidize this industry to create the
jobs that we have trained these students
for
offshore wind is one of the most
expensive and already most subsidized
forms of energy available
and that would appear to make this
primarily a special interest bill with
this provision in it
this is not green energy we're talking
about here we cherish our Coastline in
New Hampshire
we cherish our biodiversity and we
depend on it economically
there has been a long documented history
of offshore wind resulting in Marine
Mammal die-offs and damage to
biodiversity
turbines do experience failures and when
they do they often dump copious amounts
of oil
further the carbon Breakeven point for
turbines often exceeds their useful life
finally this program has inadequate
oversight it creates a commission with
the ability to spend money yet it does
not appoint a single person from this
lastly for those against the bill who
were inclined against the entire thing
please know
it is likely this bill will pass today
this amendment makes this bill better
so I would ask you to please vote Yes to
remove the wind energy pathway and keep
the Marine trades pathway in this bill
and I would ask for a division
because remember does a member yield the
questions
it's my understanding that these
windmills cannot operate with a wind
speed Beyond 35 miles an hour is that
correct
I can't speak to the specific
specifications of the windmills in
question but I do know they are in fact
Limited in their capacity to a certain
thank you Mr Speaker
this floor Amendment strips sections two
three and four from the bill
there are five sections by doing so the
amendment eliminates the non-lapsing
fund in the Department of Education that
is identified as the Career and
Technical education Workforce
Development and Innovation fund a
program fully supported by a Career and
Technical education centers
the funds shall include Federal and
other grants proceeds designated for
Workforce Development by the federal
government from the Gulf of Maine
offshore wind lease auctions
and contributions from businesses and
industries
within a section of the amend the
amendment it eliminates the commissioner
is authorized to establish procedures
for the use of said funds that's
eliminated in this section and to
disperse funds in accordance with the
committee identified in section three
this is done in consultation with the
business and industry Association the
New Hampshire Labor Department
CTE directors and Technical Education
Centers and through Partnerships with
business and industry collaborating with
the community college system of New
Hampshire
the amendment further eliminates the
offshore wind and Industry Training
Center committee that involves the
commissioner of the Department of
Business and economic affairs
the commissioner of the Department of
Education the commissioner of the labor
department the executive director of
Fish and Game
and post-secondary education this
committee shall develop a plan for
students training in skills and
knowledge at the Seacoast Regional
Career and Technical Education Centers
and Great Bay Community College
the floor Amendment further eliminates
committee responsibility for the
development of essential components
necessary for the building Partnerships
and agreements between education
business and industry this a floor
Amendment will negatively impact New
Hampshire's Workforce training that is a
key component of overall Economic
Development and job creation strategy
where state agencies collaborate with
Private Industry to provide
opportunities for our citizens the
future demand for skilled labor in the
marine and energy
Industries will be significant and
involve many positions that will require
technical skills including traditional
trades such as electricians and welders
please support this opportunity to
better prepare our Workforce for the
challenges of today and tomorrow by
voting down this anti-business floor
amendment that is a designed to cut the
guts right out of SB 152 and that has no
public hearing it's not been heard by
the public
SB 155 or season 152 has bipartisan
sponsorship in the House and Senate and
it passed the education committee with a
15 to 5
OTP vote thank you
I heard a request for a roll call who
made that request
is is that representative Phillips
that's officially second that is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote on the amendment members
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1642h
this is a roll call vote
a chair recognizes representative Ladd
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
will provide New Hampshire students the
skills and now it's necessary for
success in emerging marine and energy
career through locally developed Career
Technical education programming and if I
know this amendment will totally strip
out sections 2 3 and 4 in the bill and
if I Believe by including marine and
energy career opportunities in our CTE
programs New Hampshire students will no
longer have to go elsewhere for training
to attain these well-paying jobs and if
I also know that there are trans these
tall windmills in areas such as Plymouth
right now further north along and along
the Seacoast Maine Etc we do need to
have this training in our own state
would I then support this New Hampshire
Workforce training program by pressing
the red button
the motion before us is ought to pass on
the floor Amendment to Senate bill 152.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button your
opposed to press the red button voting
[Music]
well ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
122 voting a 251 voting a the amendment
fails
for what reason is a member rise
Mr Speaker a question of the chair
let's answer your question
in light of RSA 1449 describing
commissions describing the legislative
role in commissions and I can read that
if necessary is Senate Bill 152
divisible
two three and four are divisible
from one
thank you Mr Speaker I move to divide
foreign
ER the most the first motion before us
will be whether we authorize dividing
the question if that be the case then
we'll take up each individual's uh one
representative Poole has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
regulations
the motion before us is a question on
dividing the question
to be clear
if this motion passes 1 5 and 6 will be
voted on and two three and four will be
voted on separately
so the motion is on dividing the
question this is going to be a roll call
vote
see I recognize the representative
pool for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that our statutes require that
any committee established by the general
court have a particular makeup if I know
that that makeup needs to be less than
15 members
and more importantly if I know the
majority of that committee shall be
members of the general court
would I now vote to divide the question
chair recognize representative Ladd for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know RSA 1449
deals with legislative study committees
and commissions and if I know this is
not a legislative committee this is a
committee similar to what we have with
the higher education commission which
has no elected officials on it to
approve post-secondary education
if I know that this statute is not
relevant to what we're discussing today
as determined by attorney would I then
the motion before us is dividing the
question on Senate bill 152. this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposal
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
[Music]
president had an opportunity to vote
118 voting a 255 voting a
motion failed
now we're back to the motion of Auto
pass
it's in Asana and attesto has requested
a roll call vote is sufficiently
seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
foreign
chair recognized representative Vlad for
parliamentary inquiry representative lad
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members president and opportunity
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
250 voting a 123 voting Aid committee
what reason to memorize
to make a motion Mr Speaker stage of
table
t
majority of the committee on education
to which we referred Senate Bill 155 FM
local and act relative to the adoption
of school administrative unit budgets
have been considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpeding to legislate
Senator Glenn cordelli for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendations to Bill ought to pass
representative Alicia leak is for the
minority of the committee
now representative
Mr Speaker I'd like to table Senate bill
155.
representative Lanka says requested a
division vote members will take their
seats
the motion before us is the table Senate
motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 155 this is a division vote
chair recognized representative Ladd for
thank you very much Mr Speaker if I know
the budget approval process in this
legislation may not be appropriate for
an entirely different SAU structure and
another part of the state from where you
may be in nsau
and if I further know there are
approximately 165 unique school
districts in New Hampshire
and if I heard during the hearing
process that this bill contains many
unanswered unresolved consequences would
I then pause
recognizing this legislation is not
ready to move forward by pressing the
green button thank you chair recognizes
representative leaders for parliamentary
inquiry
if I know that this is an important
issue brought up by many of our
constituents this is a parliamentary
inquiry yes and if I know that it
therefore deserves a chance for public
debate would I then vote against the
tabling motion thank you the motion
before us is the tabling motion on
Senate Bill 155 this is a division vote
here in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
100 252 voting a 120 voting a the motion
passes
committee on Election law to which was
referred scr1
and act affirming the general Court's
support for New Hampshire's first in the
nation primary considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
of the bill ought to pass Senator
Clayton wood for the committee
this bill is a concurrent resolution
with the Senate reaffirming our support
to put this on consent and not talk
we have a century-old tradition in New
Hampshire hosting the first in the
nation primary
the first in the nation primary has been
an integral part of our political fabric
providing numerous benefits
to presidential candidates our citizens
it has given voice to The Underdogs
it's fostered an Engaged citizenry
and it's brought national attention and
however recent political events have
while the Republican party has
reaffirmed its continued support for New
Hampshire's first in the nation primary
the Democratic National Committee has
launched a full frontal attack
on our first in the nation privilege
they have reorganized their primary
calendar
to a shared second place with the state
of Nevada
and giving the coveted first place to
the state of South Carolina
[Music]
this demotion to a second place would
only be granted and and this hasn't
gotten enough attention
this demotion to a second place would
only be granted if our state met two
ultimatums
and the DNC is a private
these two ultimatums are designed to
undermine our state's autonomy
and pose a threat to our voting system
[Music]
the first automatic demands that we
repeal our state law
requiring our primary to be at least
seven days before any similar contest
the second ultimatum demands that we
pass legislation
making absentee balloting permissible
potentially opening up our voting system
these ultimatums pose a grave challenge
to our state's long-standing traditions
and Democratic principles
our state government was given an
impossible deadline to meet these
ultimatums the deadline which is now
passed was February 1st 2023.
[Music]
so now since we couldn't meet the
ultimatums
our state is relegated further down
to to not being able to hold our primary
with the blessing of the DNC until after
March 5th 2024.
this would lump Us in with many other
states who hold their contests during
so what happens if we Faithfully follow
our state law and hold our primary
before any other primary state
well the DNC has voted to impose strict
sanctions on us if we did not defy their
imposed calendar
and sanctions on any Democratic
candidates who might violate their
edicts candidates who would face
loss of delegates exclusion from debates
the motivations behind the dnc's actions
political retribution has been suggested
as a driving force
given that then candidate
Joseph Biden
finished fifth in our 2020 primary the
member will suspend
the motives are attributed in the Press
so you can find press articles backing
up what I'm saying
is The Superficial obsession
with identity politics
and what they say is a lack of diversity
some members of the DNC
have cited as rationale for why our
state shouldn't have first the nation
primary
this is an insult to our voters
and it sends the message that somehow
we're defective
because of attributes with which
we were born
we in New Hampshire disagree with that
assessment we believe in individualism
the importance of judging individuals by
the content of their character not the
color of their skin
opinions are not discounted because of
superficial
physical attributes
[Music]
these actions by the DNC not only
threaten our state's cherished tradition
but also undermine the Democratic
principles upon which our country was
founded
so now while the Republican Party enjoys
a dynamic primary with many candidates
visiting and engaging with our voters
the Democratic party is sadly left
stagnant
unable to engage with Challengers
to the president
such as Marianne Williamson and Robert F
Kennedy Jr and maybe others
this is robbing many New Hampshire
Democratic voters of the opportunity
to have their voices heard
think of it
Democratic candidates will be sanctioned
if they campaign in our state
if they spend money on Advertising
our sitting president will not have his
name on the Democratic primary ballot in
our state an ultimate snub to our voters
Democratic voters will need to conduct a
write-in campaign
if they choose if they even choose to
support him
so let's send a message today that we
stand United in our resolve to preserve
first in the nation primary
we are voting on a joint resolution that
does two things
it affirms the general Court's support
for the first of the nation presidential
primary
and demands that all political parties
respect the results of New Hampshire's
primary by seeding the delegates of the
candidates selected by our voters at
their National nominating conferences
so let's Stand Together United
a defense of New Hampshire's first in
the nation presidential primary
and against these unjust ultimatums and
sanctions being threatened by the
Democratic National Committee
I implore you colleagues and Mr Speaker
to join me in concurring with the Senate
and the Senate's resolution
preserving this tradition that has
withstood the test of time in New
Hampshire
let us not allow the divisive agendas of
others
to overshadow the Democratic principles
that we hold dear
thank you Mr Speaker
speaker
I agree that we need to provide bias
partisan strong bipartisan support as
does
all of my caucus and they are working
hard as well as our federal delegation
and the New Hampshire Democratic party
in that effort to retain the first in
the nation primary this is one of
several bills that have been before the
election law committee on this topic and
while the Democratic National Committee
can adjust their calendar
our primary date is set in statute so
they cannot change and we are not
changing our statute despite the
pressure that was mentioned by this
previous speaker
what's helped us keep the first in the
nation primary is that Democrats and
Republicans work together to protect our
primary New Hampshire worked hard over
the 20th century to grow our first in
the nation primary
all these other states that have
primaries saw the success that we have
and have followed our lead
we have worked very hard to
build it and we're working very hard to
retain it in 2008 and 2012 when the
Republican presidential primary was
being threatened by the Republican
National Committee new hampshires
Republicans and Democrats work together
to defend it and we're doing that again
this year
in that Spirit of bipartisan cooperation
I urge all of my colleagues to pass this
resolution and send a message that's
loud and clear to everyone New Hampshire
is first in the nation presidential
primary has been first for more than a
century and will continue to be first in
2024 and Beyond thank you
Sam Sweeney has requested a roll call is
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
the motion before us was ought to pass
an scr1 this is going to be a roll call
vote
Jerry recognize representative Berry for
thank you Mr Speaker
um Mr Speaker if I know that this body
Must Stand United and send a message to
not only the the Democrat National
Committee but any National Committee
that attempts to assault our first
donation primary would I now vote and
press the green button to stand with
granite Staters and uphold this
the motion before us is ought to pass an
scr one this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
members president an opportunity to vote
356 voting a six-folding a committee
majority of the committee on executive
departments and administration to which
Susie's World Senate Bill 149 FN act
relative to nurse agencies having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation to build a lot of
password Amendment Senator J.C grante
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same to be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved as
inexpeding to legislate Senator Matthew
San Andreas from the minority of the
committee the amendment is
1463-h printed in house record 22 pages
33-34. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
there's opposed me
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass as amended chair
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker Senate Bill 149 is a reaction
to a real problem however it will do
nothing to solve the problem but rather
exacerbate it
this bill attempts to solve the later
labor shortage in nursing and lower the
cost of nursing labor by making it more
difficult for nursing agencies to do
business in New Hampshire write
contracts provide transparent pricing
and hire employees
Mr Speaker the government does not
understand that people respond to
incentives they expect that when
sentences changed then people will
behave exactly as they did before
by adding licensing to nurse agencies
not only do we increase compliance costs
requiring nursing communities to charge
more but we discourage the allocation of
nursing labor into New Hampshire
compliance costs include people filling
out paperwork in the private sector and
people filing paperwork in the public
sector these are people that could be
doing something useful in reducing the
labor shorts this bill is pretending to
work on
if we want our health care facilities to
have more access to labor then we would
open the doors wide open instead of
adding compliance rules
additionally if a nursing agency is
found to be out of compliance they will
lose their license and be forced to do
business outside the state and take
their traveling nurses with them
Mr Speaker this bill stipulates the
conditions about how agencies can commit
nurses to facilities
this should just be an agreement between
the agency and the health care facility
making it more difficult for these
organizations to contract with each
other does not increase the number of
nurses in the economy and it does not
decrease the demand for nurses in the
economy it will only make the health
care facilities more desperate and agree
to contracts that are more onerous and
expensive
Mr Speaker this bill prohibits under
which conditions a nursing agency May
charge higher prices
like if a health care facility has a
virus or isn't a jurisdiction that isn't
a public health emergency
if I'm a nurse and I'm offered a bid on
two jobs
one where there is a deadly virus and
another whether it's not a virus and the
pay Must Be The Same by law then I will
take the one without the virus
this is precisely why Humanity invented
prices so we can appropriately allocate
resources
if one Health Care Facility has unique
dangers then in order to encourage
nurses to work there they must be paid
more
in order for the agencies to get nurses
into areas with these conditions they
must pay them more
it will have to be paid for somehow the
agencies will have to increase costs
across the board or somehow otherwise
obscure pricing from the reality in
Mr Speaker this bill is against free
speech and freedom of Association it
states that nurse agencies shall not
recruit potential employees on the
premises of a Health Care Facility
in order to enforce this totalitarian
methods would have to be used to ensure
that nurses who are assigned to the
facility be put on a gag order as far as
the conditions on their employment
besides the Free Speech issue how does
increasing advertising costs for the
agency reduce overall costs
Mr Speaker in reality labor is a scarce
resource this is why it requires the
distribution of paychecks in order to
obtain it today many Industries are
competing for labor
the reason for the high labor costs are
varied and complex it is not as simple
as pointing a finger at the nursing
agencies and blaming them for everything
and then adding arbitrary rules and
Hoops for them to jump through
this legislation exists only to make
people feel good about themselves
pretending to be accomplishing something
thank you Mr Speaker
when I came here today I didn't know I
was going to be speaking at the well I
am a nurse and I'm straight out a night
shift
I can tell you that this legislation
would be very detrimental to my
profession
um
I would tried to get a hold of the New
Hampshire Nurses Association but on such
a short time because I didn't know that
this bill was on the docket today
um I wasn't able to get in touch with
them to find out what their position is
but I have
I have worked as a travel nurse before
um and many people you know many of my
co-workers have as well
if New Hampshire can't recruit travel
nurses because they're prohibited by the
legislation that might pass today
um
basically the the travel nurses are just
going to go to Massachusetts they're
going to get higher contracts there and
that's going to put New Hampshire
nursing is in a desperate place right
now I can tell you that
um
and
I don't know why a lot of people are
talking right now I'm trying to tell you
what I experience in my profession
we are desperately understaffed and
travel nursing is a Band-Aid to put to
get our patients the nurses that they
need on such a short time frame but it
doesn't solve the long-term problem of
low Staffing
um and when we don't have enough staff
it's the patients who suffer
so
it's not meant to be like all the time
travel nursing because that is very
expensive for the hospital but it is
meant to be a Band-Aid until they can
get more staff and the way to get more
staff is to recruit more people into the
profession but we actually have a
problem with having enough nursing
instructors in the college and that's
where the stop Gap is so that's a
separate that's a separate conversation
but I feel like this
um legislation is
is detrimental to my profession and I
can't support it thank you
SBS SB 149 is
sp49 addresses issues that arose in
hillsborough's counties nursing home and
it was confirmed by other County nursing
facilities as well
due to the shortages of nurses in New
Hampshire nurse agencies Personnel are
used to fill shifts in case
sorry Phil shifts at Health Care
Facilities
it is often the case that at the last
minute
a staffing commitment from the nursing
agency is pulled
from a county home and the staff is
reassigned to a higher paying facility
this has led to an increase of 155
percent in nursing costs
in New Hampshire per the New Hampshire
Hospital Association who testified in
support of this bill
as did County management and nursing
the office of professional licensure and
certification is responsible for the
rulemaking pertaining to the
requirements of this bill Mr Speaker I
encourage you and ask you to pass this
for what number does reason as a member
rise for a motion Mr Speaker motion I
moved to place SB 149 on the table
that is a proper motion
the motion before us is to lay Senate
bill
149 on the table the division has been
the motion before us is the table Senate
bill 149. this is a division vote care
recognize representative Osborne for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that I just heard a
number of concerns from previous
speakers uh regarding this bill and I
know that we still have a couple weeks
before the deadline and that if those
concerns were to be addressed in in the
next two weeks that we could bring this
bill back off the table and deal with it
at that time would I now press the green
button
can't recognize representative Grody for
Mr Speaker if I know that house bill 149
addresses a problem that was mentioned
by the County nursing homes and other
health care facilities in New Hampshire
that led to an increase of 155 percent
in costs that are brought down to our
property taxes and if I know that this
bill addresses these this issue by
preventing nursing agencies from
switching at the last minute their
personnel from one facility to the other
Mr Speaker what I know would I please
vote against the tabling motion so that
we can truly pass this bill a bill that
is needed in New Hampshire by our County
Municipal our County governments thank
you
motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 149 this state division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button to your poster press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president and opportunity to
199 voting a
173 voting a Senate Bill 149 is placed
sure
the majority of the committee on Fish
and Game and Marine Resources to which
was referred Senate bill 14 FN an act
relative to the use of game cameras
having considered the same report the
same what the recommendation at the bill
ought to pass representative Jeffrey
goalie for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution result that it is
in expedient to legislate representative
James splayne for the minority of the
committee
the bill is on set excuse me second
reading and opens a further Amendment
representative Spillane moves floor
Amendment 1520 and is recognized to
thank you Mr Speaker
this amendment is a bipartisan amendment
that was drafted with between myself and
my good friend the member from
Manchester the vice chair
sb14 came to the committee with uh some
deep concerns for all of us that we
could agree on that no landowner wants
surveillance devices placed on their
land without being aware of them that uh
no matter how much land you own
you should have the right to know that
somebody's placing surveillance devices
the only place where the committee
differed and we couldn't come to terms
in the committee was on how extensive to
make that change and in what manner
but the vice chair and I got together
and crafted an amendment that we are
presenting to you now that fixes some
problems with it but still supports the
ability for the landowners to have the
Sovereign right of their land without
having somebody
unknowingly Place game cameras or
cameras of any type that can record
pictures video sound and Etc
I would hope that you can support this
amendment and press the green button
representative Hines is recognized speak
thank you I agree with the premise of
the underlying bill but I think there's
drafting issues with the amendment and
also some issues with the original Bill
itself definition the definition of game
camera if you take a look at it is so
broad it includes dash cameras it
includes any surveillance cameras on
your house I think people have a right
to have a camera on their house pointed
at their own property and I think the
amendment doesn't address that when it
speaks at 300 feet of permanently
occupied dwelling I have neighbors
within 300 feet of me I don't think I
should need their permission to have a
camera on my property pointed at my
property further any cars that have a
dash camera or a century version and
there isn't many cars I cannot even
drive on someone's driveway
um just based on definition so while I
appreciate and I like the
premise of the underlying bill I think
the question is on Amendment 1520 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment's
adopted
for what reason does remember rise I
moved to table
representative Hines moves to table
Senate bill 14. I asked for a division
vote this will be a division vote
the question is whether to lay Senate
bill 14 on the table representative
Heinz is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know the
premise of this good bill is good but
the language is bad and I think dash
cameras should not be illegal and I
think people deserve to have
surveillance cameras on their own
property faced at their property when I
then support the table so this bill
could be reworked thank you
representative goalies recognized for
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment has nothing to do with needing
permission to put a camera on your own
property
then would I press the red button and
the question is whether to lay Senate
bill 14 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
thank you
foreign
[Music]
members presence had an opportunity to
vote
the house will attend to the state of
46 in the affirmative 321 in the
the question now is on
ought to pass with Amendment on Senate
Bill 14. are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the
and Senate bill 14 is referred to the
Senate Bill 52 comes to us from the
committee on science technology and
energy
without recommendation relative to the
regulation and operation of electric
vehicle charging stations representative
Corbin moves out to pass and offers
Amendment 1401 h
representative Vose is recognized to
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
could you tell the body where this
this is printed in house record 22 pages
27-28
thank you Mr Speaker appreciate that
I rise in opposition to this amendment
simply because this amendment does not
when this bill was originally introduced
it was substantially different than it
and the reason for that is because the
body that considered it was quite
skeptical
about the provisions of the bill
so they did what they often do they
this amendment does not address the
Bill's original intent
our committee sdne considered the
language changes in this amendment and
decided that they did not address the
major concerns with this bill
therefore we can't support this
amendment
and we ask you to press the red button
and Mr Speaker I asked for a division
vote
representative corman's recognized speak
thank you Mr Speaker uh first thing I
would point out is that the St e
committee actually voted in favor of
this amendment 14-6 uh the amendment is
mostly removing a few things but the
main thing it does is it removes the
Public Utilities Commission from the
bill because it's just premature to have
the puc involved so therefore I would
ask you to support the amendment and
simplify this bill so that it can be
questions on Amendment 1401 H and this
is a division vote members please take
[Music]
foreign
Amendment 1401 H representative Vos is
thank you Mr Speaker I'll simply
reiterate what I said a few moments ago
if I know that this amendment does not
make an unnecessary Bill necessary
if I also know that this bill was
substantially different when introduced
and the study committee that
the bill ended up being is not going to
address the issues that were brought up
by the initial bill when I now press the
red button
to defeat this amendment thank you
representative corman's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill this amendment actually passed the
committee 14-6 so it had Republican
support and if I know that this
amendment actually makes the bill more
focused would I then press the green
button and vote for the amendment
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
1401 H and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red voting
today
[Music]
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
thou shall attended the state of the
vote
183 in the affirmative 183 in the
negative the motion fails
the amendment fails
thank you Mr Speaker
Senate Bill 52 establishes a committee
to study EV charging infrastructure and
its funding
I'm sure you all remember when our
grandparents in this legislature
authorized a committee to study building
and funding gas station infrastructure
it was necessary so Massachusetts
terrorists could drive their new
Horseless carriages
to our ski resorts
otherwise they were all going to go to
no that didn't happen
but you will be told it's necessary now
and that the committee needs to look at
the funding sources beyond that coming
from EV users
Roman meals tax
credits from business profits business
Enterprise and state utility tax taxes
and enabling local property tax
exemptions
actually our grandparents let the free
market create the needed infrastructure
of those times
and it can do so again
with no rate payer and taxpayer
Beyond trying to extract money from
non-ev users the committee itself is
redundant
in 2018 this legislature passed the New
Hampshire Transportation Council it's
embedded in RSA 238a
it has the authority to quote study
methods of implementing new
Transportation Technologies and modes of
transportation and the logistics of such
Technologies and modes
in 2020 the council's membership was
restructured to include the
Commissioners from the Department of
energy and the Department of
Environmental Services
the council has the power to accept
gifts and grants
the department of energy and the
Department of Environmental Services
have over 21 million dollars of non-rate
payer monies that can be used for Ev
projects
so this bill is both ill-conceived and
unnecessary
push the red button to itl
chair recognizes representative Corman
Mr Speaker uh so I haven't met everybody
I am Tom Corman from ward 3 of the city
of Lebanon and I stand here before you
to support SB 52.
if we don't build it they won't come
the it
is fast charging infrastructure for
electric vehicles EVS
and that they
are the tourists that much of New
Hampshire's economy depends on
because this bill is really about the
future of tourism in New Hampshire
the overwhelming majority of tourists
from out of state come from nearby
States and provinces and they arrive by
motor vehicle
what kind of motor vehicle will tourists
be driving in the not too distant future
we are going to see a lot of EVS ISO New
England the regional grid operator
forecasts more than a 50-fold increase
in EVS by 2031.
from 35
000 to 1.9 million that's just for New
England add in the other nearby States
and provinces and you get the picture
it doesn't matter how any of us in this
chamber feel about EVS
the fact is
they are coming
and we had really better be ready for
them because we sure as heck are not
ready now
New Hampshire has only half as many
publicly available charging stations as
either Maine or Vermont
our state is a desert for fast EV
Chargers especially north of Concord and
that's where people go to ski or hike
think about a potential visitor with an
EV coming from say Southern New England
New York New Jersey Quebec Ontario or
New Brunswick
they will ask I can get to New Hampshire
but can I get home
if the answer is no then they're not
coming here
they're going to Vermont or Maine to ski
or hike and our tourism industry suffers
so ski areas and other tourist
attractions lose significant sales as do
restaurants and lodging to give you an
idea of the numbers we're talking about
in 2021 New Hampshire welcomed 14.3
million visitors who spent 6.3 billion
dollars that's with a B which generated
328.3 million dollars in tax revenues
so we had better be ready this bill SB
52 establishes a committee to examine
how to fund EV charging infrastructure
not so much about the EV Chargers
themselves but about how to get the
power to where the Chargers are going to
be fast Chargers require a lot of power
and getting that much power to them is
often not possible with the existing
infrastructure it is not something that
we can rely on the market to provide
the committee will review existing state
and federal funding sources along with
existing funding by ratepayers and it
will examine additional non-rate payer
funding sources
this lays out a menu of possible
additional sources and yes as my friend
from Southampton pointed out some items
on the menu are taxes but other possible
menu items are fees paid only by EV
owners and users and also incentivizing
private capital
the bill allows the committee to choose
items not even on the menu it'll look at
how other states do it and the committee
will take input from the public and
relevant state agencies
there is the New Hampshire
Transportation Council and my friend
from Southampton did quote the charter
of the council correctly study methods
of implementing new Transportation
Technologies and Mojo's Transportation
throughout the state but they're not
looking at the power infrastructure and
how to fund it by contrast this bill SB
52 lays out a committee comprising only
four members three from this chamber and
one from the other side of the wall with
the focused goal of suggesting how to
fund the infrastructure between the grid
and the meter serving the EV Chargers
how to come up with the funding isn't
returning to what SB 52 is really about
imagine what our tourism industry would
be like if we had only a handful of gas
stations in New Hampshire because that's
what it will be like in just a few years
if we don't get ready to outfit EV
charges our tourism industry would
collapse and taxes paid by
out-of-staters hey our favorite kind of
tax will plummet
and so if you want to see those sweet
out of state dollars continue to roll in
then please press the green button and
vote for the OTP motion on this bill and
for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker to make an alternate motion
go ahead
I moved to table Senate bill 52.
representative Hall moves the Senate
Bill 52 be laid on the table
I would ask for a roll call vote and
request a roll call vote is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
the question is whether to lay a Senate
Bill 52 on the table this is a roll call
vote representative holes recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
if the two members that I just heard
speak
about this committee about something
that is going to potentially increase
taxes
for the rate payers if I further know
that electric vehicles currently do not
pay the role excuse me the roll the road
toll tax what I now vote Yes to table
of corman's recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill just creates a study committee it
doesn't actually raise any rates or any
taxes and that it could be crucial to
the future of tourism in New Hampshire
would I then press the red button so
that we can vote on the bill itself
the questions whether to lay a Senate
Bill 52 on the table and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house let's enter the state of the
vote
183 in the affirmative 188 and a
might as well stay in your seats because
now we're on the main motion of uh to
representative Bernardi is recognized
this is a division vote and we are on
representative Vost is recognized for
thanks Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know
that studying electric vehicle charging
station infrastructure is an ongoing
effort at the Department of
Environmental Services the Department of
Transportation and the statutory
statutorily authorized New Hampshire
Transportation Council
if I also know that this bill's study
committee duplicates much of this effort
and exists primarily to study ways to
fund such infrastructure by shifting
costs to all taxpayers
finally if I know that consumer demand
will set the pace for the build out of
EV charging stations
what I then press the red button to let
EV fueling stations evolve in the same
way that gasoline fueling stations did
thank you Mr Speaker
representative Wendy Thomas is
is on tourists visiting our state and
spending their money on our attractions
restaurants and hotels
and that the state takes in well over
300 million dollars annually from
tourists visiting our fabulous
attractions like our mountains Santa's
Village Storyland and yes whale's Tales
and if I know that ISO New England
predicts that there will be more than a
50-fold increase in electric visit
electric vehicles just in New Hampshire
by 2031
on top of all of the electric vehicles
from States outside of New Hampshire of
New England
and finally if I also know that New
Hampshire is considered a charging
desert
in New England because we lack the
infrastructure to provide for those
electric vehicles resulting in those
tourists instead visiting other states
where they will spend their money
would I now press the green button so
that we can prepare New Hampshire for an
electrified vehicle future in order to
attract and keep tourist money in our
the question is on the motion about to
pass on Senate Bill 52 and this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button if you're opposed press
the red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote I also attended the
187 in the affirmative 184 and the
for what reason doesn't remember us
Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side I would move
reconsideration and ask the body to vote
no and I requested
representative Weber moves
reconsideration on Senate Bill 52 and I
requested division are you ready for the
question vision I'm sorry Division
division division
division all right division we'll do
division
this will be a division vote members
please take your seats
the question is whether to consider the
previous vote on Senate bill 52.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button if you're
opposed press the red voting stations
have all members president and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attempts at the state of
the vote
185 having voted the affirmative 187 in
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was deferred Senate Bill
69 FM relative to allowing certain
non-profits to participate as a customer
generator group hosts under net energy
metering comes to us without
recommendation representative McWilliams
moves ought to pass
representative Perez needs recognized to
sb69 expands net metering by raising the
net meter cap from one megawatt to 5
megawatts for an estimated six and a
half thousand non-profits in New
Hampshire
let's do a little back of the napkin
math if just two percent of the six and
a half thousand non-profits take
advantage of the new limit that would be
an additional 650 megawatts of
intermittent power added to the grid
currently New Hampshire has an estimated
400 megawatts of net metered electricity
therefore this bill has the potential to
more than double the amount of
electricity being net metered from
unreliable sources
so what is wrong with expanding net
metering a report commissioned by the
Public Utilities Commission and
published last October found that net
metering does cause cost cost shifting
whereby regular electric customers end
up subsidizing the practice of net
metering by a small number of other
customers for that reason this
legislature has been very careful and
deliberate and expanding net metering
over the years
furthermore two bills we passed last
year HP 1599 and SB 261 require the
Public Utilities Commission to take up
the issue
of cost shifting and the puc has taken
the other issue that comes up with debt
metering expansion is reliability
when the utility buys electricity from
the wholesale Market those purchases
come with contractual obligation to
produce power this means the utility can
they can be sure that the producer has
an incentive to deliver reliable power
over the length of the purchase
agreement on the other hand when
utilities purchase net metered
electricity this comes with no
contractual obligation when the power is
actually in demand a net metered
customer can choose not to sell into the
grid and conversely when there is low
demand the customer can force the
utility to buy
utilities cannot depend on net metered
electricity to reliably power the grid
to avoid blackouts and interruptions in
power the grid operators have to make
sure that there's always a backup of
reliable power ready to kick in to keep
things running
for every extra megawatt produced by
solar there has to be an equal capacity
produced by other more reliable methods
in conclusion nothing prevents
non-profits or any other individual or
business from producing more than one
megawatt of electricity for their own
consumption
they just can't force the utility to buy
access at the premium price this bill
would force utilities to buy more
unreliable electricity at the premium
price
New Hampshire Department of energy does
not support this bill and New Hampshire
consumer Advocate also does not support
expanding net metering I urge you to
vote red against the OTP motion on sb69
thank you Mr Speaker
representative munz has recognized speak
thank you Mr Speaker and good morning
colleagues
I rise today in support of the motion of
OTB for SB 69.
this bill will enable not mandate New
Hampshire non-profits who are able and
wish to invest in projects themselves to
obtain the full benefits of net metering
on projects up to five megawatts in size
New Hampshire is currently the one state
in our region that arbitrarily limits
the size of these projects to one
megawatt
it will also give smaller non-profits
the opportunity to collaborate and share
both the cost of investing in these
projects and the returns from them
New Hampshire nonprofits are an
important part of our state's economy in
2019 they employed over 83 000 Granite
Staters which is 15 percent of our total
Workforce and accounted for 13.5 percent
of our state's annual gross domestic
product
New Hampshire nonprofits bring people
together to shape and improve the
quality of lives in our community
in 2019 over 329
000 Granite Staters volunteered at one
or more of our non-profits they are an
important part of the New Hampshire
advantage
every dollar a non-profit can save makes
a difference whether they can continue
to deliver the services to many of our
family families friends and Neighbors
whenever possible we should do whatever
we can to support and assist them
One Way new nonprofits can save money is
to invest in renewable energy the most
popular example being solar panels
once panels are installed the cost of
every kilowatt hour generated and used
is negligible in addition as you already
heard under existing law any individual
or organization who chooses to invest in
renewable energy projects can also
receive a credit for any power they
generate but do not use and are able to
sell back to the utility that is what is
referred to as net metering
you will hear as you already have that
because net metering that that because
this net metering mechanism already
exists this bill is unnecessary
however under existing law non-profits
are only able to reap the full benefits
of net metering on projects up to one
megawatt they invest in themselves
this creates a challenge for most
non-profits because The Upfront
investment costs of most renewable
energy projects are typically too high
for most of them to afford on their own
in addition the optimal size to generate
the greatest return on investment for
most projects is in the three plus
megawatt range
the additional revenue from net metering
this bill will provide to non-profits
will reduce the payback period on these
Investments improving the attractiveness
of investing in them and providing
non-profits with an important cost
saving opportunity
it will also help to reduce our regions
over a Reliance on natural gas which is
what drove up an electricity prices this
past winter and places us at further
risk in the future
now much has been said about the alleged
cost shifting that some suggest occurs
from net metering this is an idea that
most of us without solar panels will end
up paying more for electricity than
those with solar panels
Skeptics of net metering have correctly
observed that when our utilities
purchase unused power back from their
customers they end up paying more for
that energy than if they were they
purchased it from the wholesale Market
exactly how significant a difference
that is depends on the the vagaries of
the of the energy Market
however many of these Skeptics usually
admit
the fact that net metered projects also
result in significant benefits to all
rate payers
from the power grids perspective
generating your own power and using it
locally is exactly the same as reducing
demand it reduces The Strain on the
regional transmission system and frees
up capacity on the grid to move more
bulk power to where it's needed most
utilities see the benefit of this effect
in the form of lower Regional transition
transmission and capacity payments and
those savings are passed on to all of us
the question however has always been
what is the cost benefit ratio how much
are the costs and how much are the
benefits
we finally got an answer that question
this past fall
the New Hampshire Department of energy
hired a team of independent Consultants
to use the best available data to try to
answer the question of whether the cost
of net metering outweighed the benefits
the results of that study showed that
while at some point in the future we may
start to see some sort of cost shift
that day is far off
we can leave our existing net metering
rates in place for 10 more years and
only then might we see a one percent
increase in rates
but that same study also found that
while rates may rise the average
electricity bill
granted Staters pay will go down because
net metering encourages local people to
invest in local generation and receive
the benefit of that investment in the
form of lower monthly costs on their
bill
sb69 is an important bill not only for
the many non-profits and their employees
who do so much good work across our
state but for all granted Staters the
one thing everyone here can agree on is
that we need to address the rising price
of electricity that is impacting our
constituents
and we all are united I think in the
notion that we should be we should be
energy independent and no longer rely on
foreign sources of energy
SP 69 is a very small proposal for how
we might start to do that it will
encourage investment in local power
generation at a scale that makes sense
for our non-profits and it will lower
operating costs for this important
segment of our economy which will end up
benefiting all of us
I urge you all to vote ought to pass on
SB 69 and Mr Speaker I ask for a
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on Senate Bill 69.
representative Santo nastazo's requested
a roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members please take
receipts
foreign
[Music]
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on Senate Bill 69 and this is a
roll call vote
representative Vose is recognized for a
speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that New Hampshire
is one megawatt limit on net metering is
not arbitrary
but is in fact a guard rail to protect
our state's rate payers
and if I also know that our state's
consumer Advocate who serves to protect
the interests of our state race rate
payers opposes an expansion of net
metering Beyond one megawatt
if I also know that expanding net
meeting metering to as many as
6500 non-profit groups could
substantially increase electricity costs
because net metered power has a lower
value than the reliable power delivered
by utilities
and finally if I know that the
department of energy advises that policy
makers should wait until the conclusion
of the public utility commission's
current proceeding about net metering
before making changes to the Law's
provisions
but I now press the red button to
preserve a guard rail that protects all
representative Christian is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire's
non-profits contribute substantially to
the well-being of New Hampshire citizens
and if I know that the one megawatt
limit for net metering was put in place
because we heard that we needed to wait
to understand its impacts on New
Hampshire
and if I know as my colleague just
explained that those impacts were stated
to be very minor or positive
and if I further know that this bill
would allow our non-profits to make the
choice to save money without causing or
costing anything to other rate payers or
to do Hampshire taxpayers when I now
press the green button and support OTP
the question is on the motion about to
pass on Senate Bill 69 and this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor press
the green button if you're opposed to
press the red voting stations are open
foreign
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
186 in the affirmative 186 and the
for what reason does a member rise for a
table
representative Weber moves the Senate
Bill 69 be laid on the table you ready
for the question
okay all those in favor say nay
foreign
clarifying vote nobody in nobody out
the question is whether to lay is Senate
Bill 69 on the table does a division
vote voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
oh
Lane
representative Tripp is representative
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
okay
the house of attendance state of the
vote
190 an affirmative 181 and the negative
the house the house will be in order
depending on science technology which
was referred Senate Bill 79 relative
participation of customer generators and
net energy metering comes to us without
recommendation
it's a Reynolds moves ought to pass the
chair recognizes representative
Harrington
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to this bill
unlike the last bill there's no limits
on who can participate in net metering
on this other than the limits that the
market causes because of size and
dollars in other words any large
corporation no matter how big they are
will be subsidized by the rate payers to
put in net metering if this bill passes
it takes acres and acres to put in a
five megawatt system or at least 20
acres and hundreds of thousands of
dollars the overwhelming majority of
businesses in New Hampshire don't have
the room and or the money to do this so
we're talking about large corporations
like Stony field yogurt who testified in
favor of the bill because they want to
see their electric bill go down at the
expense of the rate payers
as it was said in the last bill the
consumer advocate of New Hampshire does
not endorse any expansion of net
metering over one megawatt because he
realizes it causes a subsidy by the rate
payers and rates will go up if this bill
passes the previous speaker on the other
bill which applies to this well mentions
studies the doe study but that was based
on one megawatt cap not a five megawatt
there's a huge difference there and
there's a potential for hundreds and
hundreds of megawatts to come on the
market and again just as in the last one
none of these megawatts would have an
obligation to provide any electricity at
any time that's the difference when the
utilities sign a contract for default
Energy Service they could go to a
supplier and the obligation is 24 7 for
the length of that contract you will
supply all the electricity we need or
our customers need regardless of whether
it's hotter than normal colder than
normal drier than normal or wetter than
normal
net metering has no provision they
produce electricity when it's convenient
for them to do so if they have a problem
with their inverters let's say for a few
days they may fix them they may not
there's no penalty for not providing
electricity but whenever they do provide
it the utility must buy it so on a
Sunday around 11 or 12 o'clock in May 65
degrees there's no air conditioning load
the company's not using any electricity
to speak of because they're shut down
it's a Sunday and there's Surplus
electricity but the utility has to buy
it and has to pay them the default
service rate and give us put some
specifics on this this past January
which everyone was panicking about huge
High rates and everything the default
service rate was 20 cents a kill about
20 cents 20 cents a kilowatt hour
the average LMP or market-based price
for electricity in New England for the
month of January was five cents that's
the difference five cents selling it
into the market default service rate was
20 cents because the default service
rate comes with that guarantee that I
will give you all the electricity you
need whenever you need it the person
selling net metering electricity has no
obligation to provide anything anytime
there's also the cost about people
mentioned about how it adds value to the
system but the problem is without the
obligation to provide electricity when
it's needed they provide no reliability
basis whatsoever so in December and
January on cloudy days on snowy days
these metering not only will they not be
putting electricity on the grid they'll
be consuming electricity because they
won't be producing enough to cover their
own load because solar panels almost go
to zero when you're talking about the
dark days of December and January
especially if it's snowing out or
raining so those times though the Grid
in the system has to be built to make
sure we can supply all the customers all
the electricity they need whether
they're producing solar power in net
metering or whether they're consuming it
so the reliability value of these
projects is almost zero it you can't say
I'll be there in June between the hours
of 11 and 4 and maybe you will it's
provided it's not a cloudy day like
today and it's raining out and you want
your power whenever you decide you have
to have it that's the problem there's no
obligation to be there it simply isn't
worth the saying I use a simple analogy
to hopefully get my point across and
that's with milk
if you have milk coming out of the cow
that has a value but the milk you buy in
the supermarket in a container has a lot
more value it's both milk it's both the
same product but one's been taken out
and it hasn't and things been done to it
the other one's been past your eyes and
add vitamin D to it and it's been put in
containers it's been shipped a couple of
times and it shows up at your
Supermarket the value of the milk and
the gallon container or the half gallon
container you buy in the supermarket is
much higher than that same gallon of
milk coming out of the cow the same
thing applies here the value of the
electricity coming out of that net
metering generator is much much lower
than the value of the default service
that comes to your house for your
utility one has an obligation to show up
all the time you want to turn on your TV
turn on more lights it's there the other
one maybe I'm there maybe I'm not when
it works for me oh I'm going to be
working I'm going to be putting on a
little extra workload on a very hot day
in in July when electric demand is very
high so I just don't put anything out on
to fall my net metering because I'm
consuming all my electricity another
time well I'm going to do the same thing
in January but I don't have any default
any electricity to put out because of
net metering so now I'm going to consume
a lot of electricity so it's not
reliable it's simply not the same
product and it guarantees to raise
electric rates if this bill passes so
thank you Mr Speaker
morning colleagues I rise in favor of SB
as you've often heard and as you just
heard from my colleague from Stratford
opposition to net metering and expanding
net metering has always been based on
this dogged insistence that paying the
Retail Energy only rate for those net
metered kilowatt hours is a big subsidy
that paying uh it's an overpayment that
must then be covered recovered from
other rate payers so that it's this
giant cost shift from the many
like seniors and single moms and small
businesses to the relatively few who are
net metering
so several years ago this legislature
directed
and our own Department of energy
conducted or at least they contracted
for and they oversaw a study which you
heard my colleague from Hampton on the
earlier Bill described
they did a big study of net metering and
a big analysis of real-time energy
supply and demand and cost modeling
that my colleague from Stratford was
referring to how the system works
and they to settle the question about
the value of net metering and that study
took several years to complete we all
waited several years and it was
completed last November it was called
the value of distributed energy
resources study so it must have been
really thorough it took several years
uh
and the bottom line that you heard my
colleague from Hampton talk about was
it a big there's no big giant cost shift
at most under the most conservative
assumptions about the way the grid
operates and real-time Energy prices and
all that at most
a one percent cost shift
one percent that's one penny on one
dollar
so in fact the value of distributed
energy resources study found that net
metered energy
is worth the retail price because it
goes directly onto the grid
directly onto the grid supplying the
next closest neighbor avoiding all
long-distance transmission costs and
virtually all local distribution costs
the New England's independent system
operator testified to the science
technology and energy committee in
January that in the aggregate all the
net metered solar installations in the
region substantially reduce Regional
demand and thus lower the market
clearing energy price for All customers
and also reducing long distance
transmission costs
our distribution utilities across the
state eversource Unitil Liberty the
co-op they all recognize that net
metered energies so Energy Systems
reduce their default Supply requirements
again lowering costs for all
now in conclusion I want to share with
you a real world example of the harm
that our
arbitrary limitation on the scale
of net metered solar arrays is doing to
our New Hampshire businesses this bill
in particular would raise the arbitrary
cap from one megawatts to five megawatts
and of course Industries and businesses
are institutions that use large amounts
of energy
and they provide large numbers of jobs
and bring produce large amounts of tax
revenue
for our state
not far from here just across the river
down in Pembroke
the associated Grocers of New England
operates an enormous refrigerated
Warehouse
a couple years ago they put up a one
megawatt solar array on their roof
because that's the largest that they're
allowed to build
and to interconnect to the grid
can't interconnect anything more than
that array produces only about 20
percent of all the energy that that
enormous refrigerated Warehouse uses
and they actually have a whole lot more
roof space that sits there empty
and unused
even though filling it with solar would
help them reduce their costs
immensely so the result of that is that
their energy costs are much higher than
they should be
and that means that the prices that
their members
all those small town Grocers across our
state have to charge for their food
are higher than they need to be
and those are the prices that our
constituents pay
so at this time when we've all been
harshly reminded about how vulnerable
New Hampshire businesses and residents
are to the whims of the global energy
Market we in this body should be doing
everything we can
to remove barriers to private investment
give our businesses another tool in
their toolbox to help reduce their own
costs
while diversifying our state's energy
Supply
and creating local jobs and supporting
local economies in the process and yes
reducing costs for all
so please vote Yes on ought to pass on
was requested a roll call is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate bill 79. this is going to be a
roll call vote
chair recognized representative voice
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the study
referenced several times here in the
last few minutes
did indeed find that cost shifts of 1 to
2.9 percent happen today
and that other studies show that these
percentages go up
and if I also know that any business in
our state can build and benefit from
from up to five megawatts of solar power
today
law does not prevent anyone from
connecting more than one megawatt of
power it simply prevents you from
collecting net metering subsidies over
if I also know that fixed income seniors
and single moms and hard-working Granite
Staters should not be obligated to help
a private for-profit profit business
earn a better return on its Investments
and finally if I know that our state's
Governor said of net metering expansion
just last year and I quote
I vetoed these crazy ideas before and if
they come back in the future I'll veto
them again unquote
what I now press the red button to spare
the chair recognized representative
Mr Speaker
I know that raising nutmeguring to five
megawatts will result in load reduction
across the grid lower capacity payments
and avoided transmission costs all to
the benefit of rate payers
and further
if I know that current technology makes
the installation of one megawatt system
often economically unviable
an image piece of five megawatts
will allow the installer the economy
economies of scale necessary to go
forward
and last
knowing that the Business Industrial
Association of New Hampshire supports
this legislation because like myself the
Bia knows that this bill is a jobs
creation bill
it will allow New Hampshire business to
allot their resources to retain
Workforce rather than ship our valuable
energy dollars out of state
would I now press the green button
knowing that I've done my part to reduce
energy costs and support our New
Hampshire economy thank you
motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 79 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button for any stations are open for
senses
ball members president an opportunity to
vote
majority committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred Senate
Bill 167 FN local act relative to Green
hydrogen energy and infrastructure
have been considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it's inexpedient to
legislate representative Doug Thomas for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
Senator Tony Kaplan for the minority of
chair recognizes
colleagues I Rise to speak against the
inexpedient to legislate motion on
Senate bill 167.
a bill to incentivize a green hydrogen
industry in New Hampshire
you may have heard of fomo fear of
missing out I've heard of it because I
am the father of three children in their
teens and early 20s who talk about it as
one of the stressors in their young
lives
I tell them I have full low fear of
losing out
because I see New Hampshire late to the
starting gate on the energy transition
we are in the process of undertaking as
a region and a nation
this bill is a bipartisan attempt to
catch us up with our neighbors in terms
of the production of clean hydrogen seen
as one of the pillars of the transition
and energy that I just mentioned
let me briefly explain what clean
hydrogen is and why it's going to be an
important energy source and why we need
this bill
hydrogen is widely available it's a
plentiful element on our planet it's the
H in H2O water and the H and CH4 or
methane
hydrogen is useful because it contains a
lot of very available energy it's much
more energy dense than gasoline for
example but it takes a lot of energy to
produce or split it apart from either
water or methane the two main sources
for current hydrogen production
the member will suspend
the member has a right to be heard if
you have to have a conversation take it
out into the ante room please
remember me continue
thank you Mr Speaker most hydrogen
produced today is used in oil refineries
as part of the refinery process or in
the production of fertilizers produce
produced mainly from natural gas or
methane in a process known as Steam
reformulation which involves heating the
Natural Gas
it's a very carbon polluting process
producing about 10 tons of carbon
emissions for every ton of hydrogen so
not helpful if you're concerned about
saving the climate from carbon pollution
the other way of producing hydrogen
splitting water molecules with
electricity gets us closer to clean or
green hydrogen depending on the source
of the electricity if you use renewable
electricity from wind or solar or
nuclear electricity you get clean
hydrogen or green hydrogen splitting the
H off the O in the water with no carbon
emissions
and when you burn that hydrogen you've
produced as a fuel you also get no
carbon emissions you just get water
so it's an ideal fuel when produced from
Green Renewables or zero carbon nuclear
energy it's light you can store it
relatively easily and transport it as a
gas or in compressed form as a liquid
so clean or green hydrogen is a small
but fast growing area of the transition
from fossil based carbon fuels to clean
energy sources that we have committed to
in order to avoid the worst case
scenarios of climate change
and green hydrogen is forecast to play a
central wall in decarbonizing heavy
Industries such as steel and chemicals
and for large trucks and airplanes where
batteries are just too heavy to make an
electric vehicle practical
it's also ideal for storing wind and
solar power used to produce it
transforming an intermittent unreliable
source of energy into a dispatchable
turn on or off of the switch grid ready
source of electricity when used in a
hydrogen-powered Generating Station thus
helping to solve the problem of
intermittency in an electricity grid
with a large percentage of Renewables
which is what we're aiming for
the International Energy agency says
total hydrogen production will need to
be around 180 million metric tons by
2030 from just over 90 million tons
today to reach our climate goals
green production of the gas is less than
one percent of the current total
production it would need to rise to more
than 90 million tons by 2030. in other
words in just seven years we need to
double our production of hydrogen and
half of that would have to be clean or
green hydrogen it's a huge job but it's
well underway the infrastructure
investment and jobs Act of 2021 includes
eight billion dollars in Grants for
clean hydrogen projects the inflation
reduction act includes more tax credits
production and investment credits for
clean hydrogen production so there's
lots of money out there to jump start
this essential industry in effect this
is a wartime mobilization or something
akin to a wartime mobilization of
resources to accomplish an existential
task for our country
Seven States including our neighbors
Maine Massachusetts Vermont Connecticut
and Rhode Island have formed the New
England clean hydrogen Hub that includes
besides those seven states a hundred
partner institutions including power
companies utilities manufacturers
universities
Etc all focused on aligning the
integration of Renewables such as
onshore and offshore wind hydropower and
solar and nuclear power into clean
hydrogen production and the evaluation
of clean hydrogen for use in
transportation including medium and
heavy duty trucks heavy industry and
power generation applications
New Hampshire is not one of those States
currently mobilizing to be a part of
this what promises to be the engine of
the 21st century Regional economy
this bill SB 167 is an attempt to catch
the green hydrogen terrain before it
leaves the station
with this bill
New Hampshire would make a bid for some
of these projects by establishing a five
hundred thousand dollar credit against
the business profits tax for a single
project for a maximum of 10 green
hydrogen projects a year
that's a good sweetener for the
establishment of infrastructure and Jobs
worth billions over the lifetime of
these projects
the bill would establish an advisory
committee tasked with identifying
barriers and streamlining the permitting
process
the committee would also identify
opportunities to integrate green
hydrogen in transportation energy
industrial and other sectors and would
also be tasked with partnering with any
hydrogen hubs in the region thus joining
with our fellow States in New England to
build a better future for ourselves
instead of waiting for somebody else to
do the heavy lifting
in short guiding and incentivizing a
green hydrogen industry in our state and
region to meet not only our energy
diversity needs but Economic Development
long-term goals to ensure our way of
life for years to come
so if you're like me and you're a secret
folo sufferer or even worse if you're
upset at New Hampshire's neutral stance
in the face of a nationwide mobilization
to transform our Energy System to ensure
a livable planet you want to make sure
we overturn this itl to show that New
Hampshire is ready to be a part of the
clean energy transition
vote red so that a better motion can be
thank you Mr Speaker
well my my colleague has given a very
good speech regarding hydrogen
a very technical speech but this bill is
not really about hydrogen it's about
establishing another committee out of
our 400 plus business committees we
already have
that will most not only have government
interference before the free market even
gets a foot on the ground
that's our primary opposition to this
bill
this bill presumes that an advisory
committee is needed to establish tax
credits and other government regulations
before the market even comes into New
Hampshire
as far as we know there's only one
manufacturer made a recent Public
Announcement about producing hydrogen
and they flatly said they don't need
this bill
that's a sign that the free market works
this bill having an advisory committee
would talk about things about
establishing tax credits regulations
and for a market that was was mentioned
previously New Hampshire didn't even bid
on a hub for hydrogen markets because we
have none here yet
we believe that the free market should
dictate when and where such action is
necessary and right now we don't see a
lot of hydrogen coming into this state
by the way the term green hydrogen was
used and that's the term that would be
used for this advisory committee to be
studying but just as an aside I won't go
into it but there are other there are
other forms of manufacture hydrogen but
they all mean the same thing hydrogen is
hydrogen you might hear the term blue
hydrogen that's manufactured using
natural gas is a term called yellow
hydrogen used by manufacturing solar by
solar only
believe it or not there's pink hydrogen
used manufactured by nuclear power only
and then the dreaded gray hydrogen which
is manufactured by oil and coal so this
advisory committee would be studying
just the use of green hydrogen
in view of the fact that we don't have a
large Market coming in here yet uh
the tax credits that they would be
studying would be placed upon the
department of energy and they have said
that they're not a tax agency so I'm not
sure if that's going to be well placed
if the if they study that
I would say there's one more thing too
we like hydrogen we think it's going to
be good but there are some concerns yet
still that were having been completely
studied yet and I will say that one
member of our majority that voted that
voted itl there's a concern that um
that there's a potential impact of
hydrogen leaks getting into our
atmosphere all I'll say on that is that
a recent article from Reuters cites four
reports that suggest more data is needed
to learn the full effects of leaking
hydrogen and what can be tolerated
before it negates its energy advantage
so I don't think we're ready yet this
bill is not ready for prime time we
don't need government interference let
the free market work when it comes for
those reasons
we ask you vote in excreting to
legislate please press the green button
thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us majority committee
report of any expedient delayed on
Senate bill 167.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpediate the
legislator and Senate Bill 167 is the
division vote
chair recognizes representative
McWilliams for a parliamentary inquiry
house will be in order
members need to be in your seats
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that hydrogen is
currently happening in New Hampshire in
Groveton we have an initial inaugural
pilot project and that more is coming
and further Mr Speaker if I know that
hydrogen is incredibly incentivized
right now by the federal government and
there is plenty of opportunity in New
Hampshire for things like nuclear to be
converted misery board within the
department of energy that has the
support of the Department of energy to
look at hydrogen would I then plus the
red button in order to overturn the itl
motion so a better motion may be made
thank you Mr Speaker
Geo recognized representatives for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that energy from
hydrogen has commercial potential
but currently there are no businesses in
New Hampshire currently making or using
it commercially
and if I also know that this bill sets
up a committee to study
investigating creating tax breaks when
finally if I know that any fast-moving
technology
where it's concerned government help or
regulation always turns out to be too
little too late
but I now press the green button to get
government out of the way of a possible
hydrogen energy future thank you Mr
Speaker
motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpected the
legislative Senate Bill 167 this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your pulse or press the
red button voting stations are open for
um
all members president an opportunity to
187 voting yay 186-148 committee report
committee on ways and means to which was
referred Senate Bill 51 FN and that
creating a commission to study terrible
gaming and historic horse races and
relative to the moratorium on license B
historical horse racing facilities
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that bill ought to
pass so John junijian for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it committee report is
adopting
committee on Ways and Means through
which was referred Senate Bill 104 FNA
an act to regulate online gambling and
direct net proceeds to a community
college education scholarship fund
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution is all that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Fred to
set for the committee
move indefinite postponement of SB 104.
the motion is in order the motion before
us is indefinitely postponed Senate bill
104. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
I suppose nay
the eyes have it in Senate Bill 104 is
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was house will
be in order
to which was deferred Senate Bill 195 FN
enact relative to purchased the steel
products that buy American
certification having considered the same
report the same the recommendation at
the bill ought to pass as they see
growth in the committee
um Mr Speaker I wish to make a motion to
special order SB 95 to its regular place
on the next House calendar next calendar
and you may speak to your motion thank
you
cannot be fixed without a floor
Amendment which has been drafted and is
in the clerk's office so we would like
to present that to you
to the house next week at the next house
session and I would we would like to
have it on the organic calendar
the motion is the special law to Senate
Bill 195 are you ready for the question
the eyes have it in Senate Bill 195 a
the committee on Fish and Game and
Marine Resources through which was a
forward Senate Bill 15 FN and act
relative to the use of tree stands and
observation blinds instead of the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation to go on a
password Amendment Ellen Reid for the
committee
the amendment
committee amendment is
1381 H printed in-house record 22 page
25. you ready for the question on the
the eyes have it in the committee
amendment is adopted representative
spleen office floor Amendment
1588h it's in your seat pockets
and chair recognized representative
spleen
thank you Mr Speaker
esteemed body we passed this bill uh
some months ago
and the body on the other side of the
wall is not uh enthusiastic about it and
in order to drive home the fact that we
believe that
we should repeal the ban on brass
knuckles blackjacks and slung shots I
have asked us to please attach it to the
back end of this bill from the Senate
that we're sending back over to them
um I hope this is or from the other body
I would really appreciate your support
and I hope you'll join me in pushing
green on this amendment
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues I rise
today to ask for your support in
defeating this harmful and unnecessary
Amendment
what blackjacks and brass knuckles have
to do with a bill on tree stands and
hunting blinds
is something that I'll leave for the the
other representative to fill you in on
later
but the bottom line is that this
amendment would end our state's current
prohibition on carrying or possessing
with intent to sell blackjacks brass
knuckles and slung shots
greater availability of these weapons
would be one more thing
that jeopardizes the safety of our
schools our streets our bars our public
gathering places and our law enforcement
officers
when this measure came through as a
separate bill in the house it's worth
noting that neither the state police nor
the chiefs of Police Association weighed
in on it
but when that bill came before the other
body it's important to note that both
opposed it
so please join our law enforcement
community in opposing this unnecessary
and harmful change to a good bill that
was on consent for a very good reason
the motion before us is the spleen floor
Amendment
1588h a division has been requested
division
foreign
floor Amendment 1588h
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative
Mr Speaker if I know that HB 31 already
passed in the house
established the house position of
repealing this law
and if I know that the current law still
allows the holder of a hunting or
fishing license to possess or sell these
antique self-defense items
and if I know the current law
when seconds count police are only
minutes away
what I now press the green button to
pass this amendment so we the people can
choose how to defend ourselves and send
the language of
HB 31 back over to wall thank you Mr
Speaker
I recognize representative Muse for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that privacy and respect for
property rights other New Hampshire way
and that blackjacks and brass knuckles
are not
and if I know that the state police and
the New Hampshire Chiefs of Police
Association are both opposed to the bill
that the language for uh for this
amendment was taken from when it came
before a committee in the other body
and if I'm also opposed to creating
Christmas tree bills unnecessarily on
principle
then would I press the red button to
oppose the motion to pass this unrelated
and dangerous Amendment thank you motion
before us is the Explain four amendment
1588h to Senate bill 15.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you opposed press the red button voting
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
177 voting 896 voting nay the amendment
fails we're back to the motion of Auto
pass as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
Paul's name
the eyes have it in the committee report
[Music]
and this bill is returned to the
the chair recognize the member from
Auburn representative Osborne for third
they resolved that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time at the reading
of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered a third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today a be to meet at the call of the
chair
question
is on the third reading motion are you
ready for the question all those in
we still have announcements and
unanimous consent so please everybody
care recognized representative Marjory
good at good afternoon
and as soon as this session is finished
if you would make your way outside to
the lawn you will see that UNH has its
usual spectacular barbecue waiting for
you and also some wonderful research
projects that you could look at and take
great pride in what our State University
foreign
County Executive Board meet in the
anti-room for just for a few minutes I
just want to give you an announcement
thank you
a reminder that Republicans will caucus
in the hall directly right now after
everyone leaves we will not take too
long so there hopefully will still be
some barbecue left for you outside when
we're done
Jay recognizes the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker just a couple of quick
announcements one in the house calendar
at the beginning of the House calendar
on page two you will see there is a list
of 2023 house bills amended by the
senate senate at the beginning of today
we took up five of those bills this is
where you will find the list as well as
online of the house bills amended by the
Senate so please be mindful of that we
take those up at the beginning of house
session next food and beverage in the
chamber this is your
weekly reminder no food or beverage in
the chamber lastly when we have a guest
singer when the speaker announces that
the members that the person is
performing for us please do not sing
along only sing along if the speaker
announces that somebody is
joint or is leading Us in singing thank
the
chair recognizes represent
representative Gorski for unanimous
consent
one thing I've learned as a speaker it's
it's very difficult to go right in front
of lunch
but if you can uh thank you colleagues
for indulging me just for a few minutes
here
I want to take this opportunity to
officially welcome my cousin Ava her
husband John oneanus a one of her sons
Sebastian to New Hampshire
their other son Damien and his wife
Kasha could not make this trip this is
their first trip here to the U.S in
their first
trip to New Hampshire
Ava and I met five years ago
Ava and her family live in Poland
approximately 45 minutes from the
Ukraine border
but let me tell you a little bit about
this extraordinary family
since February 2022 at the first influx
of the Ukrainian citizens at the Polish
border
Ava Janus and Sebastian have been
involved with assisting their Ukraine
Neighbors
they have welcomed multiple sets of
people into their home during their
transition from living in Ukraine to
traveling to relatives in other
countries in helping them find them
helping them find permanent housing in
Poland Germany and other countries
they made two two to three trips per
week into the Ukraine at the beginning
of the war
in the cigars transported approximately
three tons of food blankets diapers and
other household items on their way into
the country
these items were needed by those
displaced from the U from Eastern
Ukraine into Western Ukraine
in those who did not leave their country
on their way back to Poland on each trip
they stopped on the Polish side of the
border to transport refugees to
temporary shelters it often often to
their own personal home
some of their humanitarian efforts
included visits to supply orphanages
hospitals in Ukraine centers for for
eternally displaced citizens
the offered orphanages quickly found
their limits exceeded as many young
families brought their children to the
orphanage for safety so that both their
parents could assist in the war efforts
where they were not packing trucks and
Commercial Vans to make trips into the
Ukraine they were organizing the
collection of the most necessary items
from the various communities from other
European countries
Aver through her work had contacts in
Austria and was able to have items
collected there and shipped to Poland
for distribution to the refugee centers
there are other days that they simply
traveled to the border crossings to
transport refugees to the centers
there were several trips that touched
their hearts in which they welcomed
people into their homes on one such trip
Sebastian
packed up several older women in a young
girl
he learned that the teenager was
handicapped with mental and some
physical disabilities
this is a small group that could not be
dropped off at the refugee Center so
they placed them
uh
this small group that could not drop at
the refugee Center instead invited them
into their own home
the sinewa's other son Damien and his
wife Kasha welcome Ukraine families into
their home
Kasha also regularly cooked food and
made Refreshments for the refugee Center
and for a people placed in their Village
the majority of the work that the
seniors did in Ukraine was a cooperation
with the mayor of their Town who
contributed with mayors of the Ukraine
towns visited by them
this ensured again that Goods would be
received by most in need
in closing I am in awe of their efforts
over an extended period one final
footnote the family with the support of
the mayor has filed to create a
non-profit organization which will
provide them certification as a travel
charitable organization
their non-profit is close to being
finalized called the narrow promachi
Roxy
fellow colleagues I'm very proud of my
cousins and their family in their
efforts
and the New Hampshire house has made a
declaration expressing our appreciation
for the humanitarian efforts
in closing it's declared by virtue of my
signature inscribe below the House of
Representatives does publicly thank Ava
yanu Sebastian Damien and Kosher for
their selfless efforts and for reminding
us of what humans do best
in that it is to help one another
without question without fail dated
fourth day of May 2023.
thank you for joining us
joining us in the gallery today
we have the pleasure of having the swing
our family who have traveled from Poland
on behalf of the House of
Representatives welcome to
Representatives Hall and thank you for
everything you've done to serve those in
Ukraine at this time I'd like to present
you with a house declaration and commend
for what reason does the member rise
Mr Speaker I would move that the remarks
of the previous representative speaking
and your own remarks be placed in our
do you recognize representative Edgar
okay I guess as some of the members Su
21 were going to come up if they want
okay this this past Monday a ceremony
was held at the winacon at High School
auditorium in Hampton
the plaque installed above the
auditorium entrance reads Robert R
Cushing Jr Auditorium
this Auditorium is named in honor of
Robert Rennie Cushing Jr
70.
for his dedicated service to his
hometown of Hampton and the people of
New Hampshire as school district
moderator and a member of the New
Hampshire House of Representatives
it was in this Auditorium that Rennie
served as a moderator of su-21
which serves the towns of Northampton
Hampton Hampton Falls Seabrook and
Southampton
he served as moderator from 1994 until
he passed last year
Britney also served many terms in the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
at the ceremony the chairman of su-21
school board spoke of his rennie's
the present principal noted that it was
probably better for him
that he was not principal when Rennie
in addition to being an excellent
football player you know ready managed
to organize walkouts refused to shave
his sideburns and maybe a few other
things
some thought a plaque outside above a
chair
just outside the principal's office
might have been another place for it for
was really good and fitting they're
ready was recognized for as many as
accomplishments by naming the auditorium
[Applause]
what reason did memorize Mr Speaker I
moved the remarks to be placed in the
representative Osborne moves that the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills and role build
amendments and roll Bill reports from
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye Mr
President you guys have it
good
the house is in recess to the call of